[Music]
let's go to christopher in spokane
washington what's up christopher
hey um a quick question i guess i'm
gonna try to make it quick
so i'm a local truck driver
and work
at night time delivering pizzas but i
have an opportunity to
leave washington state go to alaska
work for
summer it's seasonal work
how to be dropping my local
truck driving job
to go to alaska is it a fishing job
uh no okay i had a buddies in the desert
for the cruise industry yeah okay cool
what's that what's the payoff if i go to
alaska what happens
so if i go to alaska i can pay off all
my debt
by october and have ten thousand dollars
when i come home
how old are you
34.
are you married
no
no kids
no kids but
you were saying and we cut you off
but finish the sentence
but um
i would be losing my health benefits and
everything
and i would be pretty much jobless and
homeless when i
get done okay first of all that's a
little dramatic okay christopher come on
you scorched her and i'm gonna be
homeless and nobody will love me and my
grandma's gonna take her socks back
well wait a second you're gonna be debt
free
you're gonna have ten thousand dollars
going towards your emergency fund which
is baby step three what is three to six
months based on your current income
uh current income yeah what's three to
six months expenses
probably eight thousand okay wait a
second so now we come back from alaska
we have no debt
we have a fully funded let's call it
three months is that based on three
months i'm guessing the 8 000.
and i'd probably use that money
you what
i would use that money when i come back
together no you would not no you're
being melodramatic i'm gonna show you
how
so stay with me in my narrative we'll
get to your narrative if you don't like
my narrative
all right our pets heads are falling off
come on yeah i mean man the sky is
falling okay so listen you come back and
you've got 8 000 in your emergency fund
you got 2 000 left over so we know
you're not going to be under a bridge
starving you're going to at least have
plenty of lifetime supply of ramen
noodles for two thousand bucks okay so
here's my point you also were in a high
demand job as a truck driver true or
false
true
you also will have communication
instruments otherwise known as phone and
email while you're in alaska true or
false or pigeon in small pieces of paper
fair i mean for heaven's sakes you gotta
hire a dog to deliver a message all
right so so you can you can communicate
back in your area and go hey it's
possible that your your current employer
may need you back because you're not a
jerk and you do a good job is that true
or false
that could be true all right dude come
on so what's that what's what what's the
hang up okay yeah
you sound like someone's forcing you to
do this
no i'm just wondering if it's worth
doing
because i'll be dropping
where i here i pay rent and everything
else and food and everything but in
alaska i won't be paying that
right so you're pocketing even more
money so if you don't go how long until
you pay your debt off that's the
question i would say 18 months all right
then so do you want to pay it off faster
or in 18 months
faster then go to alaska
and eat some great salmon
and then don't cut your arm off because
you don't have any health insurance yeah
i mean you're okay you could self-fund
your any health needs
so man you're on a cruise ship what if
what if i have really a really bad
gallbladder
and
wait a second
do you have a bad gallbladder or a
history of gallbladder
okay
then maybe not having insurance is not
the plan for you
so then don't do it we're not telling
you to be risky but let's play this out
though
um
are you talking with a doctor now are
you in care right now to where they're
going it could we may have to remove
your gallbladder in the next year two
years i mean what tell us what the
doctors are telling you
uh they just uh they told me that it
could go it could not go if you eat
healthy then
you could potentially have a your same
gallbladder or the gallbladder forever
if you just eat healthy well you could
be talking about me right now and i've
never been diagnosed with any
gallbladder issues that i'm aware of
knock on wood i mean i hope it stays but
here's the deal what would a gallbladder
surgery
cost you without without insurance
maybe ten thousand all right then so you
start weighing
do i want to go to alaska or not i mean
the
thing is is that there's a small chance
that that could happen i guess but uh at
that point you go okay
well could i afford it
and you're also christopher
man you're talking a few months to pay
this off right as you say october
versus a year and a half
i think this is a different conversation
if it's six years or yeah that's true
eight months then i would tell you dude
you roll the dice you live once dude
right now man it's six months half dozen
another i agree if you're worried about
the the risk of the gallbladder stuff
and being saddled with a ten thousand
dollar bill
uh then then don't do it i would go i
personally would i'd eat really good i
would well i don't know man i may blow
my gallbladder up on a cruise not me no
if i knew my gallbladder might blow up
i'm gonna go i'm going to the google and
i'm going what's the good gallbladder
but they have those cheesecake buffets
well the buffets are an issue i agree